tatsächlich haben das langweilig oder
deswegen ist doch viel schöner wenn die
stattdessen ein eigenes gemüseanbaus
deswegen kommt hier ein video für
absolute gemüsegarten anfänger in dem
ich dir schritt für schritt zeige wie du
in dein allererstes gartenjahr staat ist
und bevor du deine gemüsebeete anlegst
musst du dir natürlich erstmal überlegen
wo dieses schätzchen denn überhaupt
hinkommen sollen also wo der beste ort
ist um dahin gewesen ein tolles zuhause
zu bieten und erster tipp den ich die da
auf den weg geben möchte ist dass je
näher das gemüse an deinem haus wächst
oder da wo du regelmäßig vorbei kommt
desto besser für deine ernte seien desto
mehr kriegst du mit wenn schädlinge sich
an deinem gemüse vergehen darüber
sprechen wir am ende auch noch mal was
du dagegen unternehmen kann nicht aber
wenn du die wahl hast dann leg deine
beete da an wo du immer vorbei kommt es
möglichst nah am haus ist wo man mal
schnell raus springen kann um kräuter zu
ernten wenn man gerade am kochen ist und
denkt auch irgendwie fehlt noch ein
bisschen pepp in der suppe aber
natürlich gibt es auch noch ein paar
andere sachen die man beachten sollte
die meisten gemüse mögen es eher in der
sonne zu wachsen als im schatten also im
ganz schattigen bereich kann man
überhaupt nichts anbauen im halbschatten
geht noch eine ganze menge dazu habe ich
auch mein video gemacht dass ich euch
gerne unten verlinkt also man muss
natürlich immer das beste aus dem machen
was man hat wenn es bei der total fertig
ist dann bauen natürlich trotzdem dein
gemüse an der geht nämlich noch eine
ganze menge aber so sachen wie gurken
oder tomaten zucchini auberginen also
die besten gemüse wachsen vor allem in
der sonne und deswegen versucht auch ein
sonniges plätzchen für ein gemüse zu
finden dann ist es auch ganz gut wenn du
darauf achtet dass es möglichst eben ist
also nun ganz steilen hang zu gärtnern
ist nicht so einfach das gießwasser
fließt ihr weg die erde wird
abgeschwemmt der muss halt nicht auf
seinen beeten das heißt da müsstest du
ein terrassen beete anlegen was
natürlich viel aufwendiger ist als wenn
du gleich ein ebenes plätzchen sucht
aber wie gesagt macht das beste aus dem
was du hast wahrscheinlich wird niemand
der hier zuschaut den perfekten standort
für seine biete festlegen es gibt immer
sachen mit denen man ein bisschen zu
kämpfen hat und das ist ganz normal die
größe eines gemüsegartens festzulegen
das wahrscheinlich gar nicht so einfach
also ich habe am anfang gar nicht genug
haben können aber gerade wenn du noch
gar keine erfahrung hast ist es
natürlich erst mal schlauer nicht zu den
riesen großen gemüsegarten anzulegen
sondern erstmals
ein kleiner anzufangen was zu lernen
aber ich finde man sollte sich auch
schon was zutrauen
also wenn du die komplette gemüse
selbstversorgung anteil ist dann ist so
eine hausnummer dass du 60 quadratmeter
brauchst wenn du kartoffeln immer noch
weiter zukaufs dass pro person
also das ist einmal um das coop
einschätzen zu können aber ich denke
dass wir im ersten jahr noch viel zu
viel da lieber ein bisschen kleiner
anfangen wobei das eine individuelle
sache ist wo so viele fragen mit
reinspielen habe ich dazu ein quiz
erstellt dass du gerne durchgehend
kannst du ich dir eben ganz viele fragen
stelle zb gärtner hast du alleine wie
viel zeit möchtest du in deinem garten
verbringen wie viel selbstversorgung das
denn sein und so weiter das gilt zwar
linke ich dir gerne auch unten in der
video beschreibung so dass du dir das
mal anschauen kannst dann hast du ein
konkretes ergebnis also wirklich eine
handfeste zahlen wieviel gartenfläche
oder eine bildfläche du in deinem ersten
gartenjahr anlegen solltest aber das
kann man natürlich auch immer noch
vergrössern also selbst wenn das jetzt
nicht super viel ist in deinem ersten
garten ja dann kannst du nächstes jahr
immer noch einen drauflegen ich glaub
ich hab den ersten drei vier jahren die
gartenfläche jedes jahr verdoppelt und
das war auch total gut so und so bald
reist wurde eine bitte hin wollen geht
es natürlich daran zu überlegen wie du
die beete anlegen könnte ist und der
klassische weg ist dass man die beete
einfach umgräbt das ist aber meiner
meinung nach in den boden nicht das
beste und auch nicht das einfachste
schüttig wenigen unsere beta anders an
mit viel kompost und ohne umgraben und
das sorgt dafür dass die beete jahre
lang dazu unkrautfrei bleiben kein spaß
und dass sie im ersten jahr schon
richtig viel ertrag abwerfen wenn diese
beete kompost fehlte das ist also eine
sehr einfache möglichkeit wie man in
einem neuen gemüsegarten schon im ersten
jahr ein richtig super ertrag bekommt
und gleichzeitig den boden show und das
bodenleben füttert also der kommen was
ist einfach mit tollen raum für die
pflanzen wurden lebewesen auf die wir im
biogarten ja total angewiesen sind dass
also rund um eine super schöne sache
wenn du wissen möchtest wie wir die
compass täter angehe
die habe ich mal ein video zu geschehen
in meinem gemüsegarten mini kurs ist
kostenlos der nennt sich das gemüse
garten gut kennt da bekommst du auch
noch ganz viele andere starthilfe in
dein erstes gartenjahr und da kannst du
dich gerne für anmelden der link ist da
oben oder unten in der video
beschreibung schaute auf jeden fall
vorbei da findest du auch die anleitung
siegel schritt für schritt deine kompost
peter anlegt und da kannst du innerhalb
von einem tag den kompletten
gemüsegarten anlegen und die hre kreisen
zu enteisen pflanzen das heißt innerhalb
von einem tag ist alles geschafft
[Musik]
das was dir am besten natürlich gerade
14 garten anfänger es ist ganz klug sich
anleger wiese zu halten die quasi von
selbst wachsen also die selbstläufer in
der gemüse welt da gibt es ein paar
kandidaten da kann man echt nicht viel
falsch machen dass es total schön wenn
man im die ersten garten ja dann schon
erfolge feiert und die ganzen princesse
in der gegend wieso welt da kannst du
dich später immer noch dran trauen
das wäre zum beispiel einmal der mangold
da kann man fast nichts falsch machen
salat wächst auch sehr sehr gut dass ein
schickeres passiert ist dass wir im
sommer immer in die blüte gehen will der
wir immer salat babys machen und
schmeckt da nicht mehr bei twitter
aber solang man das weiß ist es
überhaupt kein problem den eigenen salat
anzubauen und sich damit auch im ersten
jahr im jahr schon komplett selbst zu
versorgen ist ja auch toll wenn man so
ein bisschen selbstversorger tten in
einem kleinen bereich sein kann
kräuter wachsen meiner erfahrung auch
super gut da kann man sich auch schon
superschnell mit sehr wenig platz
komplett selbst versorgen kleine
heilkräuter apotheke anlegen und bei
jedem essen auch die eigenen kräuter mit
beim kochen verwenden es schmeckt gleich
viel besser wenn man frische kräuter aus
dem garten hat ansonsten wächst
knoblauch auch super gut darüber habe
ich auch schon mal ein video gemacht das
kann ich euch gerne in die video
beschreibung packen hat jede menge
videos die ihr euch jetzt anschauen
könnt ansonsten fürs nähen zucchini auch
super gut die bekommen oft irgendwann im
jahr milchschaum aber bis dahin
produzieren die so viele zucchini dass
man quasi gar nicht mehr hinterherkommt
mit dem essen also eine pflanze reicht
für eine kleine familie schon gut aus
wir bauen für zwei pflanzen an
manchmal auch drei aber auch nur weil
wir super viel zucchini auch für den
winter haltbar machen da haben wir noch
zwei knollen die ja auch super gut an
bauen könnte auch wenn ihr überhaupt
keine erfahrung habt das ist einmal die
rote bete die wächst auch quasi von
selber und die radieschen die sind super
schnell ernte bereit da muss man
manchmal auch dass die nicht aufplatzen
die radieschen und wenn ihr versucht
nicht zu viel auf einmal zu gießen dann
verschiedene auch normalerweise nicht
dass ihr euch auf platz was also jetzt
was in meinem gemüsegarten wachsen würde
aber welches gemüse sei denn wo in
welcher im beet wachsen und wie kann man
die gemüse vielleicht so zusammen
pflanzen dass sie sich möglichst gut tun
dass sie zum beispiel die schädlinge des
anderen abhalten oder dass sie
unterschiedliche ansprüche an
dafür haben so dass sie sich nicht
gegenseitig den bürger wegfressen
da gibt es ganz kluge
kombinationsmöglichkeiten wie man gemüse
in mischkultur anbauen kann dann ist es
auch ganz sinnvoll dass man auf die
fruchtfolge achtet das bedeutet dass man
nicht jedes jahr immer wieder das
gleiche auf ein und demselben bethan
baut sondern die gemüse rotiert so dass
schädlinge die sich meistens auf eine
gemüse familie spezialisiert haben es
nicht so leicht haben allein gemüse weg
zu fressen weil wenn da immer wieder
andere gemüse auf deinem bett wachsen
dann kannst du die krankheiten und die
schädlinge aus hungen und die können
sich in deinem gebeten nicht so
festsetzen und breit machen und die
alles wegfressen
das heißt da gibt es ein paar sachen zu
beachten und deswegen ist es ganz gut
wenn man einen anbau plan erstellt dazu
habe ich schon mal ein komplettes video
gemacht wo ich dir das schritt für
schritt zeige das ist gar nicht so
kompliziert wie sich erst mal anhört
aber eben ganz wichtig bevor man loslegt
deswegen kann ich dir das video in die
video beschreibung so dass du dir das
später wenn du ihr fertig ist anschauen
kannst dann kannst du hast in deinem
garten wachsen soll ich habe aber auch
einen fertigen pflanzplan den du dir
einfach herunterladen kannst und mit dem
du einfach loslegen kannst wenn du
darauf keine lust hast du findest du
auch unten in der video beschreibung
wahrscheinlich fragst du dich sollte ich
die pflanzen selber aussagen ziehen oder
soll ich einfach fertige pflanzen kaufen
und die einpflanzen
es ist natürlich einfacher denn je die
fertige pflänzchen kaufst aus der
gärtnerei und die anzucht spaß also
gerade im ersten garten ja und wenn du
sie noch nicht so viel zutraut ist das
eine gute möglichkeit mann hatte aber
nicht so die auswahl was sorten angeht
also wenn liga einen gemüsegarten
angelegt weil du eben lust hast gemüse
anzubauen und ist im supermarkt gar
nicht gibt und bunte sorten anzubauen
alte so halten die vielleicht selten
sind oder vom aussterben bedroht sind
dann würde ich gemüse immer aussagen
ziehen weil du viel leichter saatgut von
unterschiedlichen sorten bekommst
pflanzen in der gärtnerei da hat man oft
eine sorte oft auch noch eine hybrid
sorte also keinen samen festigt saatgut
ist so eine sache ob man das anbauen
möchte oder nicht aber es ist sehr viel
leichter sich einfach die pflanzen zu
kaufen und sie einen zu pflanzen als sie
selber vorzuziehen sogar einigen gemüsen
geht das nicht die muss man direkt ins
beet aussehen wie zum beispiel die
karotten
die pastinaken dass man einfach
wurzelgemüse wenn du dir vorstellst
würde ich dir einem kleinen töpfchen
haben und dann um pflanzen da würde die
wurzel einfach so gefreut und kaputt
kane dass das den pflanzen nicht gut tut
das heißt es gibt ein paar kandidaten
die kenne ich die hier auch gerne
einblenden
da musst du immer pflanzen aus seinem
team die direkt ins beet sehen aber
ansonsten machst du dir das leben ein
bisschen leichter wenn du dir die
pflanzen etwa aus der gärtnerei holst es
hat so seine vor und nachteile da kannst
du selber abwägen was dir darf ich dich
aber ein gemüsegarten soll ja nicht nur
das viel ertrag abwerfen auch wenn das
schon richtig ist aber er sei ja auch
irgendwie hübsch sein oder wie es das
zumindest ja für ja älter und spießiger
ich werde immer wichtiger
und deswegen achte ich zb darauf dass
ich meine beete sehr strukturiert anlege
da kann man mit dem layout ganz viel
machen kann ganze mit behandlungen
machen oder zum beispiel mit rang häfen
das schöne rang hilfen für die
gemüsebauern darauf achten dass man mit
höhen spielt also welche pflanzen werden
wie hoch und auch bunte gemüse anbauen
wie zum beispiel einen bunten mangold
oder nichts hier kohl das sind so schöne
gemüse die richtige was hermachen
artischocken sind auch tolle solitär
staunen darüber spreche ich auch ganz
viel in meinem gemüsegarten bootcamp
über das layout wie man zum beispiel im
bauerngarten anlegt also schau da auf
jeden fall vorbei wenn du jetzt dabei
bist ein neuen garten anzulegen
seine beete anzulegen da findest du auch
die anleitung dazu und auch ganz viel
inspiration was du machen kannst damit
einen garten eben nicht nur ein reiner
nutzgarten ist sondern eher so eine art
erweitertes wohnzimmer
die meisten von euch werden
wahrscheinlich nicht endlos viel platz
zur verfügung haben um da ihr eigenes
gemüse anzubauen auch wenn ich immer
stark dafür wenn das man jeden flecken
nutzt den man irgendwie viel gemüse
nutzen kann und dass er auch gleich
einen tipp den ich dir mit geben würde
so einfach ein bisschen kreativ werden
schauen wo man vielleicht noch ein paar
pflanzgefäße und kübel unterbringen
könnte dann sind viele gemüse auch
ertragreicher wenn man die vertikale
anbaut das heißt wenn man rein gerüst
gebaut und zb starken boden anbaut die
in die höhe wachsen statt buschbohnen
die nur so einen kleinen bereich im
garten einnehmen stangenbohnen sind also
viel ertragreicher dann natürlich auch
darauf achten dass man den gemüsegarten
so produktiv wie möglich gestaltet das
machen wir
zum beispiel mit kompost also wir legen
unsere bitte gerne mit kompost an so
dass die pflanzen mit allem versorgt
sind was sie brauchen und die beete
schon im ersten jahr richtig ertrag
abwerfen ein anderer punkt ist wieder
stichwort an bauplan dass die beete nie
lange leer stehen sollten das heißt ein
gemüse sollte gleich auf das nächste
gemüse folgen dazu habe ich auch schon
mal ein video gemacht zur gestaffelten
ausland und gestaffelten ernte so dass
man nicht nur einmal im frühling aus
selbst sondern immer wieder das ganze
jahr über uns sobald ein gemüse
abgeerntet ist kommt gleich wieder das
nächste drauf so dass die beete das
ganze jahr über genutzt sind und viele
leute denken immer dass das gar nicht
gut wäre wenn man die boden auslaufen
würde aber eigentlich das gegenteil der
fall weil der boden möchte nicht nackig
dagegen in der natur würdest du auch nie
so ein riesiges brach liegendes feld
finden sondern alles ist immer gewachsen
weil das den boden total gut tut
deswegen schaut dass ihr eure bete nicht
brachliegen lassen steht ja immer was
darauf an bord das ist für euch besser
und für den garten besser und vor allem
im winter wenn super viele leute ihren
garten einfach brachliegen lassen kann
ihr so viel in ihrem garten anbauen dazu
habe ich auch schon ein video gemacht
ich kann ich so viele videos und indie
video beschreibung packen also schaut
mal bei dem video vorbei wo ich zeige
welche gemüse man alle im winter anbauen
kann wenn ihr das macht dann hol dir
doppelt so viel aus ihrem garten raus
wenn wir ihn auch in der kalten
jahreszeit und das ist so schön im
winter wenn es draußen schneit immer
noch eigenes gartengemüse zu essen
ich verstehe nicht so ganz so dass so
wenig leute machen weil viele
jugendliche können so viel mehr frost
habe als man denen zutraut also macht
das auf jeden fall und baut das ganze
jahr über immer wann ihr könnt gemüse
auf warum beten und wenn ihr lust habt
auf ein video wo ich meine zeige was man
in dem kleinen garten machen kann um
dann mehr rauszuholen und schreibt mir
das gerne ich mache immer gerne die
videos die euch wünscht also auch wenn
ihr euch andere themen wünscht schreibt
mir das ist eine super hilfe für mich
weil ich möchte die videos machen wir
euch am besten weiter helfen und dann
fallen im gemüsegarten natürlich auch
jede menge aufgaben an eine der
wichtigsten aufgaben ist es dass du
deine beete mulch das habe ich auf
diesem kanal schon tausend mal gepredigt
predigt gepredigt aber wenn du deine
beta nackt da liegen lässt dann
verdunstet so viel wasser über die
erdoberfläche das ist
unglaublich deswegen deckt die immer
schön ab der mulch verrottet auch
nachher so da kannst du einfach
organisches material nehmen wenn du den
rasenmäher ist dann fällt ihre
rasenschnitt an prägen inzwischen deinen
gemüsen auf den beeten aus wenn du holz
wechsels packt die hackschnitzel drauf
wenn du stroh heißt packt das stroh
drauf oder laub im herbst dann kann
alles mögliche zum mulchen verwenden ich
verwende sehr gerne holzhackschnitzel
weil die sehr scharfkantig sind und
schnecken da nicht so gerne drüber
kriechen das ist sehr ungemütlich für
die also die kommen nicht also ich will
nicht behaupten dass die schnecken
überhaupt nicht mehr in den garten
kommen wenn man mit holzhackschnitzeln
wo ich arbeite man macht es sich doch
sehr sehr sehr viel leichter und
schnecken können ein echt einiges fanden
im gemüsegarten also denkt kleine beete
immer schön ab und nun gibt so viele
aufgaben den gemüsegarten gerade jetzt
im frühjahr aber alles sprießt und grünt
deswegen habe ich dazu eben einfach
schon ein eigenes video gefilmt dass ich
die auch gerne in die video beschreibung
packe so dass sie jetzt einen ganzen
wurzelwerk youtube marathon machen
kannst um die das alles rein zu ziehen
es wird leider vorkommen dass der eine
oder andere schädlinge in deinen garten
kommt und sich darin deinen gemüsen
bedient was ist auch etwas ganz normales
also das gehört in den biogarten einfach
dazu es ist nur wichtig dass sich die
schädlinge und die nützlinge die waage
halten deswegen ist es detail klug dass
der garten nicht nur für dich schön ist
sondern auch für die nützlinge die dann
gegen die schädlinge wirken zb der
marienkäfer ist ein ganz klassischer
nützling und den kannst du in deinem
garten locken indem du insektenhotels
aufbaust ganz viele nützlinge stehen
auch total auf trockenmauern also mauern
die nicht versiegelt sind zwischen denen
sie leben können
man kann blüten einfach mal stehen
lassen und die nicht einfach immer
abschneiden so dass die insekten dein
zuhause finden und so weiter und da
kannst du ganz viel machen um den
nützlingen in deinem garten was gutes zu
tun und dann ist es auch gar nicht so
schlimm wenn mal der eine oder andere
schädlinge in den garten kommen
du kannst aber auch eine menge machen um
aktiv gegen die schädlinge vorzugehen
einmal ist da das absammeln von zb
schnecken oder raupen das ist ganz
wichtig wenn dudar von vielen da im
garten ist die wirksamste methode um
gegen die vorzugehen
oder du denkst dein kohl am besten immer
mit einem engmaschigen schutznetz art
kann ich dir gerne auch in
wie die überschreibung verlinken was
wiederverwenden hochwertiges märz nicht
die sachen aus dem baumarkt nehmen weil
die kind superschnell cup und ich weiß
auch nicht warum bei merck der man so
einen schrott verkaufen ist einfach
schade oder hast du dir lieber einmal
richtig ist und dafür hält das dann
jahrelang genauso ist es mit lauch in
manchen orten auch mit zwiebeln und
karotten weil die auch sehr anfällig für
die c- b- und die höhenflüge sind die
kann man aber auch so beruht in
mischkultur anbauen um dem
entgegenzuwirken und das funktioniert
sagt uns zumindest in 95 prozent der
fälle wunderbar da kannst du also auch
wieder stichwort an bauplan schauen dass
du die gemüse die sich gegenseitig gut
tun die sich schädlinge und krankheiten
vom hals halten nebeneinander an baust
also überlegt ihr gut wie du deine beete
bepflanzt damit du diesen mischkultur
effekt mitnehmen kannst halten eine gute
frucht weil der ein darüber habe ich ja
eben auch schon gesprochen so dass du
nicht jedes jahr wieder die gleichen
gemüse auf seinen beeten anreist und
dann kannst du auf biologische art und
weise ohne einmal die chemiekeule aus
voran zu müssen immer noch ganz zuerst
deinem garten mitnehmen und ein bisschen
was mit dem schädling zu teilen ist auch
gar nicht so schlimm wenn dann alles
super schön läuft dann steht auch bald
die erste ernte an und ich sage dir das
ist so ein tolles gefühl wenn du dein
selbst angebaut das essen auftischt das
ist so ein stolz den man da gespielt und
ich habe das immer noch obwohl wird
schon sehr sehr lange fast unser
gesamtes gemüse selber anbauen aber es
ist einfach ein tolles gefühl wenn du
genau weißt was auf dem tisch landet was
drin ist denn da die kinder mitbekommen
wo das essen herkommt das auf dem tisch
landet also ich kann davon gar nicht
genug bekommen und ich glaube du wirst
auch sehr schnell süchtig danach werden
wir bauen immer ein teil des gemüses
dass wir im sommer ernten an um es für
den winter haltbar zu machen weil das
auch super schön ist wenn man dann noch
ein ganzes regal hat voll selbst haltbar
gemachter schätze also wenn du
irgendwann an den punkt spricht wo du
mehr erntefrisch essen kann nicht um
sommer oder vielleicht die zucchini doch
ein bisschen zu viel produzieren dann
macht das für den winter heißt es ist
superschön super tolles gefühl ich
verlinke da drüben war das video zum
anbau plan aber ich denke dass lüfter
ein sinnvoll sein nächster schritt ist
wenn du auf dem weg zu deinem eigenen
genieße ich ansonsten gera
und macht die welt ein bisschen grüner
wir sehen uns am samstag wieder an